in my last video we explored the most
mysterious enemy in eldon ring the
lookout stones we revealed the identity
of their creators and their actual name
we even got fextra to change the name on
the wiki though the url and headers
still need updating and over the course
of that search for the most mysterious
there were other enemies we saw who were
similarly shrouded in ambiguity namely
the worm faces and the cemetery shades
the warm faces technically have less
in-game text reference but thanks to
their actions placement and particular
design there is actually a bit of
readily available lore about what kind
of beings they are so in this video i
want to look at the other entropic black
hole of information peering into the
shadows let's see what light we can
shine onto the enigmatic keepers of
death's door let's delve into the lore
of the cemetery shades
in alignment with their names the
cemetery shades are found in catacombs
and hero graves we can find them three
times as boss fights and one time as a
normal lesser enemy in the gel mirror
heroes grave this one is special because
it drops the mantis blade the weapon of
choice for our shadowed subjects in this
item we find the only text reference or
description of these enemies in the
entire game it reads a curved sword with
a blade at both ends wielded by the
cemetery shades the insect ridden grave
keepers the blade is thin and sharp and
strong attack unleashes a far-reaching
slash there are two important takeaways
here the first is the name mantis blade
but i'll come back to that one later the
second is the description of the shades
as insect ridden grave keepers as we
generally find the shades as final
bosses of catacombs the title of
gravekeeper makes sense they in some way
serve as guards and or keepers of the
graves they inhabit looking after things
and attacking those tarnished who would
intrude but they are also called insect
ridden which gives reason for us to take
a closer look at the enemies themselves
zuli the witch already has a really good
video taking a close-up of the shades so
i'll just briefly touch on it here if we
look at the top of the shades we will
notice what looks like a large spider or
crab sitting atop their heads zuli notes
that the mesh of this creature is
referred to as crab and that it does
resemble a spider crab now it's normally
not something very in focus during our
fights with the enemies but we can see
the cranial creature take a more active
role during one of the shades special
moves where it bundles up and shoots a
green web and then grab attacks us
considering the underside of the crab
spider is glowing like the eyes of the
shade and the fact that thematically it
looks like a parasite controlling the
shade's brain we can probably be safe in
surmising that this creature is the true
enemy controlling the black shade this
gives a straightforward reason as to why
the mantis blade reversed to the shades
as insect ridden and i just realized
while reading this script that insect
ridden could be a double entendre of
being full of insects or also ridden by
an insect considering the crab spider is
on top and kind of riding the shade
and to touch on one more note from
zuli's video there is a multivariate
connection here to godwin and those who
live in death death root is found in at
least one of the cemetery shade areas
the black knife catacombs a place of
deep connection to godwin through the
black knife assassins the death root is
described as a source that gives rise to
those who live in death and the presence
of death is an unavoidable aspect of the
cemetery shades they certainly seem to
be in like kind with the other undead of
the game from their black intangibility
to suffering a weakness to holy damage
and there is also their ability to
disappear and teleport it's obviously
quicker but i feel compelled to compare
it to the teleporting of the tibia
mariner two foes that give death root
also having the ability to teleport just
reeks of connection to me plus there is
the aquatic theme of the mariner being a
mariner which we could say connects to
the crab parasite of the shade crabs and
water are relatively connected i'd say
and we see another possible branch of
connection in the crabs in altas plateau
those infected by death and marked with
godwin's face they are a different kind
of crab than the parasite crab more
river than spider but the overall
similarities and situation do stand with
all of the small connections plus
another environmental synchronicity we
will see later i would stake out that a
tie between the cemetery shade and
godwin's death presence is inarguable it
is just what form this takes that has
left up to interpretation is the
parasite a result of death or simply
something which latched on to a grave
keeper already imbued by death's touch
either could be likely due to the great
closeness between any grave keeper and
the realities of death after all no one
would be more surrounded by the dead
than one charged with looking after them
and their graves
we see a clear relationship with death
so now let's return to the first point
of note i mentioned the name of the
shade's weapon the mance's blade the
word mantis will be our focus as it
names an insect order technically called
mantodia or mantodea which includes
thousands of species notably the
european mantis more commonly known as
the praying mantis i must first point
out that this is another general insect
connection this is after all the item
which describes the shades as insect
ridden so it's unsurprising that the
blade itself will bear an insect themed
name but when i first recognized that
the mantis blade has mantis in its name
i was immediately struck by a connection
a praying mantis looks kind of like
another enemy in eldon ring the kindred
of rot they don't look exactly the same
obviously but an overall shape of
similarity or just a shared vibe seems
to be there to me at least and his
connection might be more than just a
similarity pulled out of my head since
one of the cemetery shade bosses has as
its item drop the kindred of rot ashes
right off the bat is the connection i
already mentioned given some actual meat
but even more the rot ashes describe the
signature move of the kindreds or
kindred in which they attack by
secreting sticky threads the style of
the attack along with the description of
sticky threads is pretty reminiscent of
the attack we saw from the cemetery
shade parasite a secretion of green
webbing these parallels make it too hard
for me to not believe in some deeper
connection between the shade parasite
and the kindreds perhaps they were
originally from the same family or order
of insects only to be influenced by
different elements and aspects of the
lands between one death and the other
rot and now they have evolved into the
different states that we find them in
game
we know the kindreds are categorically
connected to rob it's in the name and
plenty of descriptions we can even read
about it in the same kindred of rot
ashes we already looked at the rest of
the description reads the kindred of rot
are the servants of the goddess of rot
servants that have been forsaken and
there is also their weapon the pests
glave which like the mantis blade gives
some exposition about its handlers
reading wielded by the pests who emerged
from the swamp of aeonia
this glaive also shares some design
similarities to the mantis blade they
both showcase a curved blade with holes
behind the edge not to mention that
their insect based naming convention is
alike too we have pests glave and mantis
blade they sound phonetically similar
and they have the same formula of
insect's name weapon type i think this
is another point of evidence to the
kindred and crab parasite being from the
same family their weapons chart how a
core similarity followed different paths
of development and ended up as distinct
weapons the kindred are creatures which
came out of a swamp of rock following
the blooming of melania's scarlet aeonia
maybe before the explosion of rot the
kindreds would have been insects
somewhat similar to the cemetery shade
crab spider or maybe they would have
been more like what the crab spider was
before it came into contact with death
obviously these are big areas of
speculation but now that we have some
seemingly concrete connections it's up
to speculation to figure out how these
things could have been connected as this
is one of the most glorious enemies in
the game we are by design going to have
to be making a few reaches and stretches
if we hope to say anything substantial
about the shades
as the shades and kindred are now it is
hard to note any connection between the
rot and the death aspects the shades
only do bleed damage after all so i
think using what connections we have to
theorize about a possible shared past is
a good option since the enemies seem
fairly distinct now but their similar
attacks and weapons may hint at a shared
historic evolution
looking at the rest of the boss loot the
other cemetery shade drops aren't
immediately intriguing they are
comprised of more ashes the twin sage
sorcerer ashes and lutel the headless if
there's another way to pronounce the lh
and lutel please let me know in the
comments the twin sage sorcerers seemed
completely random like from software had
a drop they needed to fit somewhere in
the game and cemetery shade 2's loot
spot was just unveiled on the other hand
lutel the headless has a bit more of
relevance as she has connection to death
and graves her ashes read spirit of a
headless knight who leads the mausoleum
soldiers wields a lance and robed in
death and hurled spectral lances at foes
lutel sacrificed her life so that in
death she could continue to protect a
soulless demigod until their revival
earning her the hero's honor of urgery
burial so this is a fitting item to drop
from a cemetery shade where connections
to death and graves abound including a
specific and notable connection of
protection to the progenitor of death in
the lands between the soulless demigod
godwin lutel receiving an urgery burial
makes it more fitting that her catacomb
would have a shade to stand as grave
keeper but beyond this i don't know if
there is much to draw about the shades
perhaps this could lead us to believe
that the shades were employed to guard
important graves or that the crab spider
takes over its hosts near areas or
entities important to godwin and death
in general if we look at the locations
of the cemetery shades they seem fairly
random in terms of overall map location
however one is in lutel's catacombs and
another is in the black knight catacombs
and both of these have connections to
godwin i can't see how the lesser shade
in the yellow mirror hero's grave has
much significance but the final boss
version which drops the kindred ashes is
placed in caleb which is fitting and
further intertwines the crab spider and
the kindred to me it seems unlikely at
this point that they wouldn't have some
evolutionary connection
and if we go with the parasite being the
associate of death then we may be able
to explain some of its appearances and
explore the black knife connection in
more depth it could have appeared in
lutel's catacombs to defend a servant of
godwin it could have appeared in the
black knife catacombs to hunt or maybe
keep locked away the assassin who bore
the black knife print an essential item
in the plot which killed godwin
the presence of a black knife assassin
as a second secret boss in a catacomb
with a cemetery shade makes for quite
the piece of environmental storytelling
and it seems impossible to me that we
are not supposed to draw some conclusion
from it and we also see a headless
mausoleum knight like lutel guarding the
entrance to this catacomb with all of
this i am compelled to think of the
cemetery shade as either a parasite
hunter or a guard ensuring the assassin
will forever be trapped as punishment
for their crime the catacomb may have
been turned into a kind of makeshift
evergell either a jail or a hiding place
seem to be the only two sensible options
let me know what you think in the
comments
this catacomb also has crabs and giant
crabs plus the acts of roses the usher
of death and a figure essentially
connected to death the interweaving of
death here is absolutely everywhere so
it's a really fitting place for a
cemetery shape and the connections to
godwin really cement the relationship
between the shades and the prince of
death
as i have already said it's somewhat
hard to say one way or the other how
this connection is meant i have been
leaning on the crab spider being the
operative connection to death but it
could as well be something about the
humanoid entity it controls
if any of its attacks had deathblight we
would have more evidence to speculate a
direct line of influence from godwin we
can still do so now but with less
confidence and more uncertainty about
how this influence is coming about in my
mind there are too many coincidences for
the connection to not be something
material and while i've said that it
could be through the body the
connections that the insect has seemed
to be of much more consequence making
that the more likely route of influence
and just while i was writing this script
zuli released another video that brings
up some more deathblight and godwin
connections with insects with this in
mind i feel safe concluding that the
head parasite crab spider is the
connection to death and its prince plus
with all those flies around godwin's
soulless body and insect connection is
hard to dispute
coming to the end of what we can learn
about these shadows there's simply not
as much to reveal as in the case of the
lookout stones we already have a name
for them and we are given an explicit
title in terms of what they do there are
also a much smaller number and they
occupy fewer places still though we have
seen connections that are not
immediately apparent during a normal run
of the game the parasitic spider crab is
just the tip of the insect-ridden
iceberg these shades are tied to death
and godwin in a number of ways from
protecting his entourage to maybe
hunting down his killers they seem so
acutely placed in these areas that a
will or consciousness guiding them is
hard to rule out they also have their
familial connections to the kindreds but
we see that the different paths of
elemental influence have irreversibly
changed both sets of creatures
from the prince of death to pests of rot
the cemetery shades like the lookout
stones have quite a few more connections
than meets the eye in terms of what
there is that's conclusive to say about
them i think i've covered everything in
this video that said getting the
concrete down is only half the fun so
i'm interested to hear what connections
seem plausible or what other theories
you have about the shades after hearing
all of this
please feel free to present your
thoughts and theories in the comments
you can also subscribe to the channel to
stay up to date and become a patron on
patreon if you really enjoy the content
i make there is more of it to come both
in lore and broader game design
discussions with that thanks for
watching and i'll see you in one of
those future videos peace